- Or how have you rather,
been getting your message
to young people since the trip?
Because that's, you
can have such an impact
on the younger generation.
So, how do you do that?
- It's so wild to even hear you say that
because if you would've
asked me a few years ago,
like, if I knew that
I was gonna be impacting
people the way I am.
I knew I did it with my music and my dance
but to be doing it for
this is just, it's so,
I can't even tell you how
I feel about it, but I,
of course, I'm doing
my social media videos
of talking about it, but I'm
also going to schools now
and I'm speaking at the schools,
which to me is something I'm
so incredibly passionate about.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because I'm going there,
I'm in their faces, I'm talking to them.
Some of them may follow
me or know me already
but now I'm sitting there
talking about Holocaust education
and they're relating to
it in a different way.
I also did a Concert for Kindness
that was a concert to promote kindness
and combat anti-Semitism,
and anything I could do to just continue,
continue to spread no hate,
no form of hate and anti-Semitism.
- I mean, it's so funny
'cause you were like,
you know, wasn't your original thing,
but it's interesting how life
will put you on this path
that you have no idea
you're even taking, you're
just doing you, you know?
And it's incredible how you
have this huge following
and you're able to educate
while having a good time at the same time.
'Cause that's what life should be about,
learning and then also just
having a good time with everybody.
- And I wish more people
would use their platforms for-
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Just to stand up
for whatever they believe in.
- Absolutely.
Well, you were recently
honored in Washington DC
for your dedication to anti-Semitism,
so, congratulations on that, first of all.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
But what was that like, that visit?
- Ugh, I still can't even believe
that I was there, honestly.
But I was there for the first ever
Woman's Jewish Forum,
which was incredible.
And then I also got to
have a one-on-one meeting
with Doug Emhoff, who is
the first Second Gentleman
and of course, the Vice
President, Kamala Harris' husband.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he is a Jewish man.
He recently went to Auschwitz himself
and had a really intense
experience as well.
So he found out about my series
and we sat down and we
talked about our experiences
and our family's history,
and also how we're both continuing
in our separate ways to continue
to combat anti-Semitism.
- Yeah.
Can you imagine, I always think,
like, if your grandparents,
you know, could see what you're doing now,
like it's an incredible,
it's an incredible thing,
that's what I'm saying.
They survived something
and like now you're able to
keep that legacy going of,
you know, bringing people information
and not losing what happened
so you don't forget,
so we don't repeat history.
It's really cool, like
that full circle moment.
And I can't imagine watching
your daughter, you know?
And carrying this legacy
on with your family.
So, what is the most important thing
you want our audience to hear today?
- It's also, it's really amazing
and I know my Zadie, my
grandfather is watching down
and I know he's here right now
with all of us watching this,
so this is really powerful for me
to be able to be here and do this.
But, you know, speaking of my grandfather,
back then then before
the Holocaust, you know?
He was very popular
amongst all his friends,
of all his non-Jewish friends.
And the second the
announcements happened with,
you know, everything about
how terrible the Jewish people
are and about the Holocaust,
all his friends that he was
friends with his entire life
completely turned on him, beat him up,
spit on him, said, "You
dirty Jew, get away."
Friends that he was friends
with his entire life, right?
- Wow.
- So, imagine that?
Imagine people nowadays that happening,
and it does happen and it is happening.
So that's why when people say,
"The Holocaust can never happen", it can.
I mean, in Los Angeles
being here all the time,
two Jewish men were shot
outside of their temple
just for being Jewish, recently.
And there, Jewish crime,
anti-Semitism, it's so huge now.
It's one of the biggest
crime, like, hate crimes now.
So, and it's such a small
percentage of the population.
So it's like we, this starts with us,
we all need to come together to make sure
we end this together.
- Absolutely.
(audience applauding)